pour notre cas si vous deviez avoir
quelqu un bon ben voilà dans votre tête
à moi ce serait patrick bruel patrick
bleu donc dans la tête tout en haut mais
parce qu'il a une réputation meurent
jamais patrick c'est mon ami alors oui
et donc passé pour autant de crier mon
nom quoi emporter mon nom fort à patrick
banon dit patrick va pas rater
benzema est ce que vous comprenez c'est
le mec qui n'a pas été possible pour
l'instant voilà ça elle est possédée par
benoît dubois sera avec nous demain
tiens benhaim e - valérie je voulais
dire ouais vous mais neil mac roncquois
vous aimeriez rentrer dans la tête parce
que j'aimerais c'est pas vraiment le
même genre mais justement mais encore
jenny dans leur genre
elle peut la perdre les émissions ça va
ça j'aimerais bien savoir parce que
parfois vous me surprenez terriblement
jamais y est dans ma tête ça devrait
comprendre parfois votre fonctionnement
ce que parfois vous mais chez les
plaisirs franchement mon ami emmanuel
macron vous rocco siffredi non j'ai
changé donc j'aimerais bien dans la tête
de bouderbala dans l'accord pas pour
prendre de la hauteur dans mais parce
que je trouve que c'est quelqu'un que
j'adore j'adore énormément et j'ai prévu
la voir comment imaginez-vous le regard
des autres change et parce qu'il a
tellement d'humour
il a beau chez lui il a tellement
d'humour dont vous êtes en train de voir
que votre va n'a pas du tout marché
ces ripoux de ouf allenby et ben moi
j'aimerais bien être dans la tête de
mathieu delormeau non soyez plutôt dans
sa tête
[Rires]
un conseil que je donne les deux sont
acceptées a compati goût dans la tête de
joey starr
non rires on peut être à la fois
prétentieux et inculte j'aime bien
j'aime bien ça passe il faisait moins le
malin devant mais ça passe pas ça pas
d'inquiéter pas non mais ouais on peut
enlever sa photo superbe
non mais c'est vrai elles vont les
enlever sa photo ah ouais bah oui on
avait sa photo
moi oui un mois dans la tête de gilles
verdez pour voir enfin commencer
fabriquer là dedans ils pourront par le
mystère gilles verdez sachez que dans sa
tête c'est plus petit dans son nez je
suis à mettre dans la tête des banques
gelli non justement à cyril hanouna
élections là tout dans ma tête
d'abord j'aimerais bien être un homme
enlevé sa photo et non un homme poilu
plein de testostérone quoi le mérite et
je suis prêt courait jusqu'au nord est
et surtout pour comprendre un peu votre
énigmes notre complexité parce que je
pense que vous êtes beaucoup plus
complexe ce qui n'est pas laide complet
j'aimerais bien avoir sort de connexions
neuronales evo synapses et sur tous les
réseaux la prof qui parle comme ça ne me
dit pas stérile c'est j'aimerais bien
savoir c'est quoi mon délire ah oui
jadis lui a dit non tu sais moi je le
dirai si j'étais vous dans votre tête
c'est quoi votre délire études marquant
sa tête ou pas du tout de meuf on délire
de meuf mais oui on verra ali c'est
surtout qu'on verrait ce qui va nous
tomber dessus dans la gueule alors belle
attaque marché par là
moi ça me faire chier bref j'aime faire
un ennemi mais tant pis rien [ __ ]
j'aimerais dans la tête de barthez pour
savoir comment il réagit en ce moment au
fait que j'arrive en tant qu'animateur
en access prime time
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
béchir et regardez ils sont là ils sont
là dans un instant on va voir s'ils vont
rentrer sur le plateau repas qualité
moyenne dans la tête de qui toi moi
j'aimerais dans l'été de magath la tête
disent ah ouais non je me dis c'est pas
le dimanche matin pas la cote à cette
heure du match d'être cool quoi c'est
juste pour ça ouais bah j'aimerais sport
alors si vous voulez que de leurs mots
c'est tiramisu à 10 heures
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]